حربها الباردة مع امريكا وترهب
تايوان بالمناورات. وايران تزيد
اسلامية القدس ومسجد بعد احد عشر
عاما بتهمة غسيل الاموال. سويسرا
العالم اصبح معقدا اكثر. فهل من
انفراجة قريبة في الازمة
الاقصى بمثابة اعلان حرب على
الفلسطينيين وفصائل المقاومة
المضادة للسفن نبتون تطفو على
السطح بعد استهداف الطراد
من التوترات مع اسرائيل. والغرب
يواصل العقوبات على روسيا وحال
السياسي لحركة حماس اسماعيل هنية
هناك خياران فقط. اما الاحتلال
لحسني مبارك الرئيس المصري
السابق وعدد من المقربين منه.
تفرج عن اربعمائة وتسعة وعشرين
مليون دولار من الاموال المجمدة
والبطش والقرابين في المسجد
الاقصى واما الرباط وترسيخ
لمسيرتها الاعلامية منذ خمسين في
كوريا الشمالية. الصين تتجاوز
الثمانين عاما. حيث اعطى شقة
فاخرة في حي حديث تكريما
الجنائية الدولية. اوكرانيا مسرح
جريمة. وهنا ارضية معقولة تشير
مجنون كوريا يقدم هدية فارهة
لمذيعة الاخبار الحماسية ذات
شواطئ البحر الاسود وتبذل انقرة
جهودا لجلبها. اقتحام المسجد
الاسلحة يمكن للدول العربية لعب
دور مهم للغاية من خلال زيادة
انتاج النفط وتعويض غياب النفط
الروسي عن السوق العالمية. مع
للاسرى مع روسيا والافراج عن
ثلاثين اوكرانيا. المحكمة
تزايد مخاوف اجتياح الصين
لتايوان. امريكا تعزز قواتها
الروسية موسكو. تركيا تعلن وجود
اثنتين وعشرين سفينة تركية على
تهدد برد قوي على قوات العدو
الاسرائيلي. وبلسان رئيس المكتب
واسلحتها في جزيرة جوام. وهي ارض
تابعة للولايات المتحدة
في منطقة المحيط الهادئ.
اوكرانيا تعلن عن عملية تبادل
الامريكية. ومن اعمدة
الاستراتيجية العسكرية الامريكية
بمبلغ يتراوح بين سبعين ومائة
مليار يورو سنويا مع تقليل
الى ارتكاب روسيا جرائم حرب.
منظومة الصواريخ الاوكرانية
السابق بترو بورشن اقصر طريق
للسلام هو مد اوكرانيا بمزيد من
تزداد من لجوء موسكو للسلاح
النووي. القاذفات بعيدة المدى
بعد رؤية نتائج معركة دومباس.
بعد غرق الطراد موسكو الروسي وهي
بمقاطعتها في مهمات الفضاء الى
كوكب المريخ والى سطح القمر. خطة
وقاذفات القنابل هي سلاح روسي
خطير يشارك للمرة الاولى في
المانية عاجلة لانهاء اعتمادها
العميق على الطاقة الروسية وتهدف
تكتيكي. وزارة الدفاع الروسية
تحذر واشنطن من عواقب لا يمكن
الاعتماد على الطاقة الروسية
تدريجيا. الرئيس الاوكراني
الحرب ضد اوكرانيا. عقوبات
اوروبية ضد روسيا وهذه المرة
برلين الى انفاق اثنين بالمائة
من ناتجها المحلي لدعم جيشها
السفينة التي تقود اسطول روسيا
في البحر الاسود مخاوف امريكية
الدائرة مع القوات الروسية كما
اصيب عشرة الاف اخرين. العالم
يجب ان يشعر بالقلق من احتمال
استخدام روسيا لسلاح نووي
التنبؤ بها على الامن الاقليمي
والدولي اذا استمرت في دعم كييف.
ودعا زلينسكي الى تشديد العقوبات
على موسكو. روسيا تحظر دخول رئيس
وزير الخارجية ديمترو كوليبا
روسيا قد تتقدم في المفاوضات فقط
وثلاثة الاف جندي اوكراني لقوا
حتفهم حتى الان في المعارك
بعد ان حاولت دفع مستحقات
سنداتها الدولارية بالروبل
المالي الغربي منذ قرار بوتين
بشن الحرب على اوكرانيا. وفي
عن سداد سندات خارجية منذ الثورة
البلشفية في عام الف وتسعمائة
عليها. هذا على خلاف الاسلحة
النووية الاستراتيجية التي صممت
يوم نهاية فترة السماح لموسكو.
الاحداث والتطورات قال الرئيس
الاوكرانيسكي ان روسيا تعمل على
ما وصفه بتدمير اقليم دومباس
الوزراء البريطاني بوريس جونسون
والعديد من وزرائه الى اراضيها.
لمعرفتها ان واشنطن ستتجنب اي
مواجهة مع الصين في حال تم
الروسي وهو ما قد يكون احد اكبر
حتى الان لاستبعادها من النظام
مشيرة ان القائمة ستتوسع قريبا.
زينينسكي ما بين الفين مئة
السداد من خلال فرض عقوبات
معوقة. اما الرابع من مايو فهو
حالة اعلان تخلف موسكو عن السداد
فسيكون ذلك اول تخلف كبير لروسيا
تايوان? سلاح تكتيكي مرعب.
واشنطن تحذر من استخدام روسيا
وسبعة عشر. غير ان الكرملين يقول
ان الغرب يدفع البلاد للتخلف عن
وجود قوات صديقة بالقرب وربما
حتى على اراض صديقة متنازع
الائتماني. ان روسيا ربما تكون
في حالة تخلف عن السداد. وذلك
الحرب الباردة. الرابع من مايو.
قالت وكالة موديس للتصنيف
لاستخدامها في ميدان المعركة في
الحالات العسكرية في الغالب مع
فهل اخذت بكين درسها من موسكو
حقا وهي في طريقها لتطبيق ذلك في
لسلاح تكتيكي. فما هو هذا السلاح
النووي المخيف؟ الاسلحة النووية
الصين ترسانة سلاح الردع النووي
والصواريخ العابرة للقارات
جزءا كبيرا من مستويات ذروة
مخزون الاسلحة النووية خلال
اخرى. خطة صينية. تعد بكين خطة
للسيطرة على تايوان باكبر هجوم
التلويح بتلك الاسلحة المدمرة
وهو درس تعلمته الصين من روسيا.
التكتيكية مصطلح يشير الى
الاسلحة النووية التي صممت
سيجعل مهمة الغزو الصيني لتايوان
محفوفة بالمخاطر. بينما تدرس
والقواعد والمصانع العسكرية
الاسلحة النووية التكتيكية كانت
فالجبال تحيط بها جبال اخرى
وحقول موحلة من الارز ومناطق
الامريكية. وهناك هدد البيان بان
القوات المسلحة الصينية ستتخذ
مقابل صعوبة وصول الدبابات
الصينية الى المنطقة. كل ذلك
في الغالب لاستهداف عمق العدو
بعيدا عن الجبهة مثل والبلدات
وبحرية عسكرية في منطقة تايوان
مشيرة الى انها موجهة ضد
حضارية مزدحمة. وهذا ما سيتطلب
اكبر عدد من القوات البرمائية
الثلاثة وتضر بشكل خطير بالاساس
السياسي للعلاقات الصينية
الاشارات الخاطئة للولايات
المتحدة حول قضية تايوان.
اجراءات حازمة ضد التدخل الخارجي
ومحاولات فصل تايوان. رد صيني
في التاريخ. فتايوان تتمتع
بجغرافية صعبة من تضاريس مكتظة.
تايوان. وزارة الدفاع الصينية ان
الجيش الصيني سيجري مناورات جوية
وستشارك في هذه المناورات مدمرات
وفرقاطات وقاذفات ومقاتلات وقوات
مدروس. هذا هو الاستقبال الذي
اعده الصينيون لوفد امريكا في
الصين وامريكا. تنديد وتهديد.
زيارة امريكية لتايوان اتى بعدها
ايران انه اذا تعرضت مصالح نظام
الجمهورية الاسلامية للهجوم في
تحارب اسرائيل في العالم. وهذا
الدعم سيستمر. لكنه اكد تحذير
تزداد حدة التوترات بين تل ابيب
وطهران وتندلع الحرب بينهما?
ويعتزمون خوض حرب مع ايران
الاسلامي. نحن ندعم اي جماعة
صارخ مبدأ الصين الواحدة وبنود
البيانات الامريكية المشتركة
العقوبات الغربية تصل من موسكو
للقمر والمريخ. افراج عن اموال
تخشى روسيا يوم من مايو وما هي
خطة الصين لاجتياح تايوان?
اي مكان فسنرد بحزم فنحن نعلم
جيدا اين انتم حسب قوله فهل
الايدي امام تهديداتكم. قائد
فيلق القدس اسماعيل قاني يقول
فلسطيني واحد يهز كل اركان
اسرائيل لكنهم يثيرون ضجة
تحذير روسي لامريكا والمقاومة
الفلسطينية تهدد قوات الاحتلال
بيان عسكري صيني ان مثل هذه
التصرفات الامريكية تنتهك بشكل
تلك الاسلحة وبين الاسلحة
النووية الاستراتيجية? لماذا
برد كارثي. فلتحذروا. تهديد
ايراني لاسرائيل. لن نق مكتوفي
مجمدة لحسني مبارك وخطة ماكرة من
برلين للابتعاد عن غازي موسكو
برد عسكري في تصعيد خطير بين
الصين وامريكا. وبكين ترد على
ايران تهدد اسرائيل. والجيش
الصيني يرد على استفزازات واشنطن
باستخدام موسكو للاسلحة النووية
التكتيكية. لكن هل هناك فرق بين
زيارة الامريكان لتايوان
بطريقتها الخاصة. تلويح امريكي
العالمية?